في حوار تلفزيوني ممكن نسميه حوار ساخن
جدا منتشره مقاطع وحوار مو ساخن لانه شد
في الكلام وخلاص لا الموضوع وصل لدرجه طرد
ضيف من البرنامج وعلى الهواء مباشره
لاحد نحن الان نضيع وقت الحلقه نحن الان
نحن نحن الان
نحن
[موسيقى]
لانه في هذه اللهجه لهجه صغيره احترم نفسك
احترم نفسك
لو سمحت
لو سمحت لو سمحتم لو سمحت لو سمحت لو سمحت
لو سمحت اما ناقش باحترام او تفضل هذا
الحلقه لا هذا ولا حرف ولا كلمه ولا كلمه
ولا كلمه اما تناقش باحترام وادب او تغادر
او تغادر الحلقه اختر
الان تريد ان تكمل الحلقه
تفضل
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
عيب عيب عيب عيب يا سيد عيب يا سيد عيب يا
سيد عيب يا سيد تفضل غدر الاستوديو عيب
هات الورق
غدر كل ما تقوم به سيظهر على الهواء ولن
احذف مقطعا واحدا لن احذف مقطعا واحدا
تفضل غادر الاستوديو لو سمحت تفضل تفضل
غدر الاستوديو تفضل غدا الاستديو تفضل غدا
الاستوديو تفضل غادر الاستوديو لو سمحت لو
سمحت هذا الاستوديو غدا الاستوديو غاده
الاستوديو هذه تصرفات صبيانيه ولن احذف اي
مقطع من هذه الحلقات كله سيبث
طيب يعني صارت قبل وشفنا ضيوف بتنسحب من
برامج على الهواء بس مذيع يطرد ضيفه جديده
اللي شفتوه كان جزء من برنامج على قناه
اورينت والنقاش كان المذيع احمد الريحاوي
وبين ضيفوا المحلل السياسي التركي اوكتاي
يلمعزه وضع اللاجئين السوريين اللي
موجودين في تركيا وعن ممارسات قوات الدرك
التركيه بحقهم والعد بيناتهم وقام المذيع
قال الضيف مش اطلع بره وعلى فكره كمان ترى
الموضوع تطور بزياده بعد انتهاء الحلقه في
القناه اعلنت في بيان من ساعات ان السلطات
التركيه اوقفت مدير القناه على فرحات
ومقدمه البرنامج من ليل الثلاثاء من بعد
شكوى رسميه تقدم فيها الضيف وقال بيان
اورينت ان التوقيف تم مباشره بعد تصوير
الحلقه وقبل الموعد عرضها بساعه كامله
وقالت انه الحلقه كامله من غير اي مونتاج
او اقتطاع موجوده على المنصات وبتظهر كيف
الضيف التركي وجه للمذيع عبارات عنصريه
وفوقيه وم ضده ضد السوريين وطالبت اورينت
بمحاسبه الضيف على عنصريته وقالت انها
بتوثق بعداله القضاء التركي المرصد السوري
كمان لحقوق الانسان دخل على الخط واصدر
بيان طالب فيه بالافراج الفوري عن المذيع
الموقوف في مركز امني بتركيا واما الناس
وتحديدا السوريين فردات فعلا يعني متباينه
خلينا نقول في ناس في منصف القناه والمذيع
وشايفينه تصرف صح والنظف كنوسي وفي كمان
اللي شايفينه انه فعلا الضيف كانوسيء ولكن
انتقدوا ان المذيع اعترضوا وقالوا ما يصير
يعمل كذا وفي شريحه كمان ثالثه منتقده
ومغلطه المذيع تماما وشايفه انه تصرفه غير
مهني على الاطلاق لانه حول نفسه لطرفه
الخيانه
[موسيقى]